-You know my next guest from
her Emmy-nominated work
on "Stranger Things."
Now, you can see her starring in
the new movie "Enola Holmes,"
which is available
on Netflix now.
Here's Millie Bobby Brown.
Millie, thank you so much
for coming back on the show.
And thank you for doing the
first Lip-sync Battle over Zoom.
And congratulations on the win
and everything.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I really -- I really worked
hard on that.
Do you understand?
Three days I was sitting there
thinking, "What should I do
for these songs?"
And -- and this is what
I came up with.
-You crushed it. Hey.
I saw this tweet last night.
Does this mean what I think
it means?
Is season four of "Stranger
Things" in production?
-Um, I mean, I guess that's --
guess that's what they're
trying to say.
[ Laughs ]
Very obviously, I just
can't wait.
I can't wait to get back
to work.
I miss playing Eleven so much.
And, you know, to think
it's been quite a while
since I've just been on set
with my friends again.
-Yeah.
-And just playing Eleven.
You know, she's always such
a challenge to play.
And I just miss work,
to be honest with you.
-I heard that -- I don't know
if this is true but
before you got the role in
"Stranger Things" as Eleven,
you were about to quit acting?
-I was -- I think I was just
very disheartened
by the rejection, which is
something I tell everyone is,
like, this industry is such --
is just full of rejection, 24/7.
-It really is.
-Yeah.
I feel like you do get far
more -- I mean, you get nos,
a lot of nos,
before you get a yes.
And I was auditioning for
commercials,
for anything, really.
I, then, auditioned
for "Game of Thrones"
and I got a "no" for that.
And then, that's kind of
when I was like,
"Oh, this is really
difficult."
And I guess I really wanted
that role.
So one of my last kind of
goes at this all
was -- was this Netflix show
called "Montauk."
And I auditioned.
And then, like, two months
later, they just --
they got back to us, and was
like, "Hey," like,
"We'd love to -- we'd love
to Skype with you."
And then, I Skyped with them
and, you know,
the rest is history, of course.
We then named the show
"Stranger Things"
and that's -- blah, blah, blah.
But, you know, "Montauk"
was definitely the one that
kind of that hope
of doing it all again.
-And now, you're -- look at you.
You are starring in a new film
for Netflix
called "Enola Holmes,"
which I loved, by the way.
-Yay!
-It is fantastic.
My girls are going to flip.
Love it.
I'm going to show it to them
this weekend.
It's getting crazy
great reviews.
92% fresh on Rotten Tomatoes.
It's reached number one
in most countries.
Has -- it -- it's so charming.
I loved it.
I can't even tell you.
Henry Cavill --
-I love this.
This is so awesome.
-I want to go on and on.
Henry Cavill's fantastic in it.
Helena Bonham Carter.
I mean, how great, her acting?
She does like 25 faces in one
face for every like --
-Amazing. I -- just to even --
just to say I've worked with her
is just an absolute honor.
And she is, you know, I think,
one of the best female actors
in the whole entire world.
And just to have her play
my mother was just an honor.
And then, we have Sam Claflin
and Henry Cavill,
which was just amazing.
I think we had such an amazing
lineup of cast.
-Everyone knocked it
out of the park on this one,
I got to say.
It was great.
And you -- you've -- you were
a producer on this?
How -- how was that experience?
How'd you get --
-Yes.
-...to be a producer?
-Yeah.
Well, the -- the idea really
came to my family and I
when my older sister, Paige,
read the book series.
And after, kind of, feeling so
immersed by the story of Enola,
we wanted to bring this to,
you know, screens
for people to see, visually.
-Yeah.
So, my dad, with our production
company, PCMA Productions,
we found a studio.
We found a writer.
We found a director.
And we just pushed for this film
to be made.
I think, for me, I was
on this journey,
you know,
in the production side.
So it only felt right for me to
produce, and to be able to
kind of be, not only on screen
but off of camera.
And just to have an opportunity
like that was amazing
for, you know, young filmmakers,
like, you know, me who just --
I do want to make films,
and I've always been
really into that,
as well as being on screen.
-Yeah.
-So, having that opportunity
was awesome.
-You get to learn so much.
I mean, but also, I love hearing
you having a --
an English accent in a movie
because you're so --
you're so good at doing
American, that I'm like,
"Oh, she gets to do that."
-Yeah.
-Was it easier?
-Um, no,
because I like to just go
straight into
my American accent,
and I can just be like,
[ American accent ] "Hi," like,
"My name's Millie Bobby Brown."
[ English accent ] And then,
when I have to focus on
doing an English accent,
I was like, "Huh,"
because I had to say...
"advertisements," right?
So, I usually say
advertisements,
but in England, you say
advert-isements.
-Advert-isements, yeah.
-For instance, you know,
here you say privacy.
In England, you say priv-acy.
So, those types of things.
I grew up in America.
So this is like -- I'm very much
used to that.
And doing an American accent's
a lot easier
than doing an English, I think.
-How do you say controversy?
-Controv-ersy.
You say controv-ersy.
I say controversy.
But my -- my sister,
in every meeting, she's like,
"Well, that's, you know,
controv-ersy."
And I'm like, "Hey, no."
[ Laughter ]
-I love that.
You crushed it.
And honestly, the fight scenes
were great.
I -- I just --
There wasn't one second I would
be like, "Eh, that was --"
Everything was phenomenal.
I loved it.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-Congrats.
I think you have a franchise
on your hands, buddy.
It was just awesome.
-Ask Netflix, please.
-Oh, don't even have to ask.
They're going to be begging.
Are you kidding me?
"Enola Holmes."
It's so good.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Millie Bobby Brown
in "Enola Holmes."
Take a look.
[ Grunting ]
♪♪
[ Grunting continues ]
-[ Gasps ]
[ Grunts ]
[ Panting ]
♪♪
-My thanks to
Millie Bobby Brown.
"Enola Holmes" is available
now on Netflix.
When we come back, BTS
is closing out
an incredible week
of performances.
Stick around. Thank you, Millie.
-Thank you! Bye!